[Music]
hello everybody how's it going i truly
wish i had a french accent that i could
pull off right now but i don't so for a
hat that would be fun too um so today
i'm gonna talk a little bit more about
the overall french and some of the games
that whenever i think about i just go ah
that was so good i wish i could play it
again and get the same game and results
so um i'm gonna be showing you some of
those
however this is still related to the
opening series that we've been doing
i have lost count of how many episodes
of it has been
but uh we've talked about sandy the
negi's um
book for what that came out 2014-15
and um
the first year the first of the series
that he did and it's like white against
french aragon and uh philidor so we've
covered the philidor parts we've covered
most of the vinover so i'm going to show
you a little bit more about
vinover and staynets and try to do the
transition to shannon so from next week
we can just talk about
this
and
um
yeah i think it'll be fun if you
are someone who plays this as white and
if you even if you're not someone who
plays this specific
um move order as white and you play some
of the other emmy lines or sidelines
it's still okay because you get a better
understanding of the pawn structure of
the main
ideas of how the center will be where
the pieces belong and so i think it will
be cool if you
uh watch this regardless of
the
your love for the thumbnail i see a lot
of that going on in the chat
masterpiece right
as long as you're okay with it
thank you why not
let's go for a fun one why not but yeah
um so i'm gonna be talking a little
about the the winner first because
uh i've already shown you countless of
this
um whenever games and lines but just to
kind of
um make it a little bit prettier
we have talked about
c5 for the most part so i left that out
but let's talk about 97 because it's
still you know it can still transpose
right so
quick um quick buggies pop quiz what
should white do here
what do you think i would do or what do
you think um
neggy would say you should
do oh patrick that's lovely yeah you get
this a lot as white with d4 too yeah
yeah troy boy i feel that too i tried
playing
korokon and french here and there as
black and it was just not not for me and
i mean that's that's totally fine
because no one can be comfortable in
every single opening so
you know f4 is something that i have
done um not in this position but i am a
big fan of f4 f5 push push push
so let's talk about it logically let's
say you know nothing of this opening
the pawn structure indicates that
we have a very interesting kingside
attack coming up right
it also indicates that
if they take or perfect right
because i have these double bonds
now on another hand i have two bishops
but
a relatively close center right so it
also means that i need to be very
careful how i navigate these bishops
again for the most part we're going to
be doing stuff in the king side and
um because of our pawn structure there
is no knight here so if i had a bishop
queen you know this would be a new
weakness that i could explore some of
the things that black can do well one of
it is the c5 that they have already done
the other part is they kind of have to
decide when to try and do stuff with f6
and f5
the knight on f5 could be problematic
sometimes
the other parts are because there is no
dark square bishop for black it does
mean that black has weakness in their
dark squares
so this could be a new target for us to
explore
and on another hand
there is this bishop right
not really pretty but uh because of the
palm structure obviously but a lot of
the times the black does tend to try and
exchange it off so that's something that
you should be careful about
or at least weigh it in
all right so
i've talked the logistics of it
and so if you already know the opening
great if you don't buy everything that
i've talked about you should have a few
candidate moves right
all right yep thank you thank you chad
is also talking about yeah queen s4 is
good too there's so many good moves here
but queen g4 is what that kind of makes
the most sense to me because you're
going after this
um obvious weakness and here they can
play queen c7 castle all those things
that we've talked about in the last um
hours of just on psychology
but
let's talk quickly about
for example queen c7
now as queen 27 again we kind of went a
lot deeper in bishop d3 because
there is this take
and this very very cool line that you
have to know so much about
if there's also a four there's h4 do you
have to bring your queen back to d3 at
some point it's a whole thing
but um for me i didn't want to just walk
into something that my opponent wanted
to black knows well regardless of the
opponent because any anybody who plays
27 they definitely know
these to the end and i just didn't want
to walk into that so when i saw the
suggestion from negi that he suggested
you know bishop d3
was like yeah why not and the idea is
really pretty because
you're gonna eat this eventually but
you're delaying it so first black gets
to eat these two pawns right
and you get your pieces out a little bit
better than you would have on the main
line
i guess the classical line i should call
it but in this case when you do get g7
you have to be careful because
there is a very important move order
that you should know you should play
this first
with the idea
it would be awesome if the queens get
exchanged now you might ask well how
this queen is in the center my queen is
kind of stuck up there and the answer is
you are going to try to go bishop f4 and
they got to move the queen probably go
back here then you go bishop g5 again
poking a queen now think about this your
bishop is also doing a little skewer to
this knight so if the queen goes back to
e5 you can eat that knight and this
knight is the protector of the rook so
the rook falls so just kind of making
that storyline in your head of you know
what's happening should be very very
helpful now i've had many opponents play
so many different things with me
for the most part rick h8 is something
that i experienced a lot
and
if i can get this queen exchanged i'm
very very happy
and this it's very deep it's still you
know ongoing but i have a nice advantage
i have two bishops this one will
definitely fall soon i have a nice pass
pawn which is quite supported with my
rook and these two bishops so again it's
not a clear win yet but it's very
comfortable
you have a very clear plan
as opposed to opponent still needs to
develop the rook is under attack
a lot of things are happening so
that would be like the dream way of
getting it exchanged right
now let's say for example they go for
something more chill
actually
i don't think that does much because i
can still do this in worst case they
have to go back and exchange it so i
don't think that's the whole
ordeal
okay let's talk about for example take
now what do you think we should do here
is white
i think i've seen this isn't it probably
um
i mean rookish 3 was i think that was
one of the game
once i did it incorrectly
so i had to do that
but
yeah there was a one side did it like
this to try to trap the rook but that's
not good but actually drunk h3 yeah
you're right
it feels like it yeah
are you secretly trying to win us black
the rook is quite misplaced here right
and it's not really doing anything
so if we were to be able to attack it at
some point
it wouldn't stand for long
now the question is
how do we prevent it from going back
or back
yeah makes sense right
and um you are simply
trapping the rock
because it's still a quite a few moves
before you can actually eat it
but the idea is there their stroke
doesn't really have that much activity
even if it tries to even if it tries to
run away this way
whoa whoa ouch sorry
no
how did i even do that what did i do
anyways
even if it tries to run away that way
we are always capable of trying to
continue trapping it with f4 and uh keep
poking it with a queen h5 the back rank
is weak there is there's so many
problems that black has and they're like
the worst case scenario for whites
you're just kind of like long cast not
run away that way which is still pretty
scary because there is a ginormous pawn
here but
black is not fast enough in attacking
your king so
um i'm quite happy with this
now all right i'm gonna take a huge jump
back because we have already covered
queen c7 for a lot of time i'm gonna
talk briefly about
castle
so i've had less experience with castle
compared to queen c7 but i still um
think it's you you still must know it
it's a huge line and it happens way more
than
i'm happy about
we've talked about this extensively as
well and
for example this was one of the games
this line we have definitely talked
about i remember showing you uh in some
of the previous hours that we've had win
over on but
for example right now it's really
important to know your move order so
white to move what do you think we
should do
this f5 is something that i had kind of
warned you about that something that
black does want to try and do
here and there now how do you think
white can
figure out if this f5 was the right time
or not
is very possible but why h4 why not
touch five
well that's fair uh i feel quinash five
is a little bit stronger because you i
mean
queen is four is okay too but the thing
is queen h5 is at some points you might
want to move the knight and just bring
the queen back
so that just gives you the option but
queen h4 your queen is stuck permanently
in the king side
um and the other thing to keep in mind
is because there's you don't have that e
pawn anymore black does want to try and
play e5 and you know poke your queen so
you gotta move it
um
this actually this was a game that i
played in us championships um
four years ago oh my god and um
like
i felt like my position was fine
but i couldn't convert it now let's talk
about the why of it let me go back for a
second ah how do i get rid of these
arrows i do not like errors
yep bye bye era
by my evaluation gauge
yeah let's go back nice
um
yeah
so this was something i wanted to kind
of um
talk about because move order is so
important now i'm still doing everything
right opponents are still doing
everything right and you also have to be
careful because a lot of the times this
bishop g5 looks tempting but e5 and it's
not going to be as pleasant as you might
want it to be because
e4s
but
queen h5 i thought was fine i didn't
really have any
uncomfortable ideas with queenish 5 but
first you know it just started to um
fall everything starts to kind of just
fall
down so quickly
so
let me go back
what do you think i should have done
back here do you think my move order was
wrong do you think opponents move order
was
wrong and then i just messed something
up what do you think went wrong
do you want me to just leave it here or
or are you just happy with this position
if you're happy with this position then
there's nothing wrong with us
hmm
so let's first get to do we actually
like this position right now then we can
go back to
was did we do the best moves
oh i see first
forest is here
all right i'll give it maybe
30 more seconds
what happens if you play
like
g4 and antoine and rook g1
well i guess the main um so for you
are you happy with this position
not as is but
that's maybe the one
thing uh
but you can get the king side rook
involved maybe i don't know uh it's all
kind of a cramped situation
if i had pawn if this pawn for me was
like on e5 and i had this bishop of
boxing i would i would be happy with
that but right now i'm a little too
scared if i start doing stuff like that
then anytime e5 happens my king will be
up in the air
so i'm a little uncomfortable with that
now i'm gonna actually do something that
might be helpful i will share i mean i'm
i believe this link is shared with you
in the previous
um youtube videos that we did for this
specific series i will have it shared
for today as well also
sorry there's a bunch of cool but random
puzzles here
uh but the first few chapters are
are our openings now i'm gonna click on
it don't be alarmed we're not losing
this game
i'm gonna actually show you the theory
because
no not queen c7 castle yes because
and again let me do this first yeah
the answer was
i messed up
in the game that we were talking about
you guys are right white's position was
uncomfortable because
in the game that i played in 2018 i
messed up the move order i played knight
f3 first
now queen h5 makes a little bit more
sense because
now if you play knight if you play f5
now things are a little bit different
because well checkmate right
well maybe not checkmate but um you know
wicking bunch of pawns yay
uh but for me like now opponent has to
play knight g6 then knight f3
so let's go back to the game that i had
so yeah i messed up the move order so
that's why it's very very important for
you guys to know your move order and
don't trust on engine because the first
engine move is knight f3 and i mentioned
that because i have a few other
few students who are in the process of
organizing their openings and i was
trying to teach them how to be how to
have that healthy balance between engine
moves and bring their own brain moves
and master games and they would be like
well but that's the you know that's the
engine move and i would always tell them
you know have at least the first three
engine moves and then compare them to
the master games and then go a little
bit deeper and then decide which one you
want because you know just because it's
the engine move it doesn't mean it's
good
we i did the engine move right knight f3
is the first move that leeches is
talking about again leeches engine is
not super
but still
that the whole point is to not just
remember the engine troy boy the whole
point is to have do what the position
requires knight f3 makes sense and it's
technically the best move of the the
engine depending on what engine i guess
you work with um but queen h5 is the
move that you should do because you know
it stops all the f5s it forces upon 2.9
g6 then you go knight f3 defending this
and you have knight g5 ideas and for
that
now for the rest of if you are
interested in getting deeper in this
specific opening please go ahead click
on the study that will be here
and check out the game and that's
actually i think is the that one is
actually the first game yeah the
specific opening is the first game so
i can also mess my openings up thank you
man
and
yeah no i'm going to break this probably
the whole point was kind of just like
to don't trust the engine and
know your openings
despite of the engine despite inspite
anyways
okay so let me show you another one your
engine runs on gas man i
wish um okay we're going to move on from
cast the castle but i did want to talk
about
this beautiful weird c-taste d4
now
this is one of those games that's i also
played with one of the um well yeah i
played this against abrahamian and you
in 2018 u.s championship
actually it was a play the white against
her good for me uh but see like she
changed the move order a little bit i
kind of expected q7 first but she went
for take first there's nothing wrong
with that but it kind i felt like it
kind of threw me off my game because now
i don't ha i mean i'm not fast enough to
do these
you know queen c3s coming up so
after the game i was thinking and i was
like well i guess i could have
technically played this bishop d3 you
know i'm still attacking over here
if there is any attack on this then i
can just go my knight you do when it
transposes so why didn't i play that
anyways uh during the game she tried to
kind of trip me off and she succeeded
uh
so anywho i took she did that and i got
into a little bit of an uncharted
territory now here there are a bunch of
f4s there's a bunch of h4s there's a
bunch of queen back i've seen it all
i've played it all
um h4 is
not the best
in my experience it's very playable but
then again if you rely on engines you're
going to be looking at like well f4 says
0.3 h forces 0.2 but again you shouldn't
just rely on what engine says because
the engine
it doesn't have that deep understanding
of the middle game
as you could actually get for yourself
if you start watching some of the master
games ideally if it has comments in them
nowadays i think you can also learn so
much of your openings through youtube
so
well
we're here right now
yeah so i went for h4 and then she took
and
take was not the best one and i think a
part of me played h4 to also trip her
off because i could recall that f4 is
the best one but i couldn't remember my
openings because this is not the main
thing i play
and i knew she would know it more than i
do because that's the only thing she
plays
so i went for h4 and then she kind of i
think she messed up here because she
should have taken this first
but she went for take and then i kind of
started to get into
my ideas because remember the opening
that i was talking about with the bishop
one d3 is the pretty much the same
position just with the bishop on d3
so i kind of knew that this position is
fine because i have nice um i have good
two bishops i have better uh development
i have this very amazing pawn that if i
can just start pushing it'll be great
but i also didn't play it as accurately
so far so good but i didn't play it as
best as i should have
and she slipped away and the game ended
in a draw within the next honestly
actually 10 moves
man i thought it would have been better
all right i'm going to do another huge
jump back are you guys ready boom
wait you got to this position on the
game right yeah uh what happens oh
yeah so that's kind of the point again
engine is not it doesn't make sense when
it says plus three but it's not really
winning i have cleared i have advantage
but i still need to be able to find the
exact right move order which i didn't
for example here it says you should go
bishop v2
and try to pile up on g4 or g4 which was
my idea but i did i was hoping to
not to let her go f5 or e5 so i tried to
you know kick the rook away a little
and i thought that this is favorable for
me because if the king is on f7 and i
get this it's
more comfortable
but then if i go bishop d3
um now you know she
she can't play f5 but she has e5
so if i go over here it's still good
but now the problem is she has center i
don't have that much um i actually have
no central pawns i could have control
over center you know but that's not it
so um
here i played f4 to try and stop e5
she just developed i'm doing what engine
also is recommending it's giving me what
plus 2.5
and again i'm doing everything i should
be
but for example here saying play bishop
e2
just the engine
and so yeah my whole point is kind of
like um
it looks good but it's
not it doesn't feel plus two
plus two it's usually much more clear
than that
if you wanna feel comfortable in it
like here right now engine is saying go
g5 who cares you know if take actually
take so that's we can't care about that
but if take then what
take over here
take that take that
well i'm a little scared of this
honestly
are we going g6
oh i guess not just yet because then
they can block us here maybe this check
first
i'm not saying that i didn't this
position doesn't have advantage but i am
saying that it's like when it shows plus
three plus four it's a very arbitrary
number and it really really depends on
well
how much time you give it
and um
opponent does have counter play here in
the center
there are so many
ways that she could take control over
the center so it kind of takes away
my advantage
or the
it doesn't take away the advantage it
takes away how easy the game
should be when it says plus three
does that make sense
cool
all right
i'm going to do a big jump because
there's a whole different line i want to
show you
uh okay oh yeah
so there is this um this take as well
and
i don't understand it somebody played it
with me and then they just refused to
play c5 or b6
and they went for queen d7 so i was just
like okay
i'm assuming you want to do this
but on that note let me go back here
sorry sorry
yeah queen d7 that's something that um
zotonsky played against me
in u.s championship 2020
so not the last one that went before
that
and um
it was kind of weird because
27 like i had some preparation but i did
not really feel that comfortable in it
because i
didn't truly understand
what was the reason behind it to be
honest i still don't
so if you do please tell me
um
i just kind of went for uh
the a3 take take
and
i thought she has a clear idea and i
wasn't sure if or how to stop it so i
just went for what i knew this is a weak
pawn let's go poke it
all right f5 i'm going to take a second
and kind of ask your opinion
what do you think we should well i
should do here as white
this is what this is indeed one of my
most favorite games
there are two other games in this um
today that i want to show you
so i'm
really hoping we'll get to it
also what's going on in the chat
who is a heavyweight champion
there was a guy who was using the name
of a former heavyweight champion
to be a creeper oh we're all joking
about how he's no longer in the chat ah
yes ah the creepers youtube stuff
i don't know why i'm imagining a crepe
right now
i'm not hungry i had so much waffle
today
i found this really nice place
somewhere
downtown and it was really good it was
like smoothie
something but
anyways
thank you comment comment comedy and
entertainment
all right
what do we feel are we taking that are
we moving the queen
that's kind of your two choices so
yeah i agree these f5s are a little
weird to understand from both sides uh
blacks you know black's idea is your
queen is poking me i need to kick your
queen away
if you on position it's amazing i'll
take with the knight i'll start figuring
out how to play e5 and i'll make you
regret ever having touched this epon
so i guess that takes away
the ampersand idea so what else you got
yeah
so check giving this check on his fool
giving this check on his wife is
interesting the problem that i
encountered was this queen came here and
then the queen gets to go to f7 and then
my queen has to move again
and then they quit this queen on f7 is
actually pretty good right this queen
stays here
and after i move my queen this queen is
just
a protector of their king side i didn't
want that so i kind of wanted to make
sure this coin stays a little bit more
pointless so i just kind of went
queenish queen g3 my idea was okay i'm
still going to poke this so no 97 for
you just yet she won bishop a6
kind of got to take it
she took back
i went
92. i'm
i'm not sure if i wanted to castle just
yet but i was preparing for it
um
i think i was trying to decide where if
i want to go like bishop g5 but if i
play bishop g5 i give you 97 because
i've cut my queen and i can't attack g7
anymore right
the other part of it was if 92 um
if if i castle too early you might start
getting creative with that side
probably not just yet but i'm assuming
there will be a queen of 7 at some point
the
third part of it was maybe i could keep
the kink here for just a bit longer and
maybe stabilize my knight on f4 and try
to kind of
bring more uncomfortable ideas to your
g7
so see troy boy i didn't want to make a
draw early on first of all she was high
rated so she would have probably said no
second of all i really wanted to do good
because it was this championship and
third of all
there's a lot of money on the line so
med school tuitions man
all right uh no i'm not opposed to draws
and i mean i think draws are fun i have
had so many draws that i wasn't just
feeling like that would be
my position to play and i offered drawn
sometimes they accept actually the
funniest offer drawer i ever made was
i i was playing so many tournaments in
2016 like within the first three months
i had more than 50 raided games classic
crazy games and i was so tired
and
i had scored my first two i am norms and
then i was playing in austria league and
i was so close to costing 2 400 which
means your your k changes right but at
the same time if you cost 2 400 live it
counts towards your title for in the
future but if you cross 2400 but you
know you lose a game middle of the
tournament you question 400 but then you
lose a game and your rating doesn't
you know cross 2400 in the next rating
list
then your k doesn't change so i wouldn't
be k10 i would still stay k20 so i
really wanted to change the case because
i wanted to
actually i don't know why i cared that
much but i wanted to cross 2400 because
i wanted to
be 2400
and um it was i was playing two games in
austria bundesliga i won the first one
and then i quest 2400 live
and then i was playing a second one and
i was calculating okay if i win it great
if i draw it still stay above 2 400 if i
lose it i get like 23.99 and then i was
like oh
and my opponent was lower rated but i
had a really worse position like plus
two and i had some counter play and then
i was like you know what every time i
was lower rated and the higher rated
opponent has a worse position they offer
me a draw i i either like think 30
minutes and get so low on time that i
mess up later or i accept the draw so i
was like you know what that's how i'm
gonna do that i'm gonna be the person
who abuses their rating and i did that
so i just looked at her into eyes and i
offered to draw in a really worse
position she started thinking and after
half hour she just accepted it and i was
like yay so i crossed 2400 but that game
if it continued i would have probably
lost
or i would have been very uncomfortable
for the remainder of the game
so
my point being draw offers are welcome
but it should be well thought out you
shouldn't just go around and be like
draw draw draw
that's not gonna fly well
okay
what is your
there is a k factor of 42
but i
deeply hated it oh my god that killed so
many raiding hopes if you're under 18
and you can like you play one game with
somebody who is like 300 points less
you lose to them boom you lose 40 points
you win them you're like what you get
like what three four points same but if
so if you're like um if you're under 18
and you haven't crossed 2 300
that's k40
good luck to you if you're one of those
i think italia suffered and enjoyed
quite a riot with k4k 40. i haven't
heard of that that must be is that
feeding yeah okay
well we care a lot about you know
crossing that specific rating barrier
because of the norman titles which are
video thing i guess unless you're
thinking about nm
okay
that was a quick little detour on
my funniest
um
i like kayton i don't know why oh
no oh
i lost chat
you lost your chat that was my mistake
oh
maybe tracy is logged in nope she's not
can i send you a link or do you need me
to open it manually um i can pull it on
my laptop oh i can actually i should
play booktube i think i might remember
my my passwords let's see if i do
while we do this i'll just show you this
part and now i'm going to ask you please
come up with a good idea for white like
a long-term plan give me like a four
move plan five move plan
and don't be like i'm gonna eat this
then i'm gonna eat this then i'm gonna
eat this this
so don't do that give me like a five
move straight strategic plan while i
remember my password
okay i think that's at least my email
now let's see
do you
back up on want me
yes i know my passwords
but i don't have chats
just say the word
yes please
oh there there i am
yeah
i don't know
i have something here
how do i yeah
oh
pop chat
thank you
how did i not know about the pop-up
chats i don't know
it's good to know i remember my
passwords though i always forget them
okey dokey
all right somebody's talking about
knight f3 first that's a legal move
so
and this is tea it's a very good
smelling tea i found a few years back
when i was playing moscow open and i've
been addicted
okay so
somebody um
egym is going with bishop g5 and then
queen d3
possible
a lot of people are thinking queen d3
you're not wrong we should start doing
stuff in the queen side but if you buy
queen d3 they're either gonna go king b7
or knight b8 and that doesn't really
help us
um i don't think anybody has said this
uh idea that i played yet oh yeah
greenfield thank you
yes this tea was green yeah greenfield
spring melody yep
watch their amazon sales go
i wasn't suggesting you advertise it but
you can
i mean i like the tea they have a nice
chocolate or honey as well
those are my three top
all right um yeah it's good i don't know
about c4 though see
why why c4
i'm a bigger fan of just pushing this
guy i mean your rook is here your pawn
is here feels logical no
and it's not like opponents can a5 it
so anna went knight b8 with me and then
i just pushed a5 she went knight c6 so
i'm like okay well let's open up the
rook so far logica right but see it was
one two three moves that you could have
been like okay maybe i want to cast them
maybe i want to do this maybe i want to
do that instead of all those
for nobody's taking your castling rights
away and nobody is attacking your king
just yet or opening the center to see it
so your king is okay where it is so it
was a good idea to spend these three
moves opening up your rook
now uh in the game i was trying to
decide between like bishop a3 or castle
and i couldn't and i was just like you
know what let's just go castle but if i
need bishop e3 i'll go bishop a3 because
i was assuming she's still not gonna
play this because i will still eat it
so
i was kind of still waiting on
i wanted to see what she would do
because 97 i was i was assuming she's
not gonna go h5 because the knights just
gets here i was thinking if she goes g6
well great i'll probably just go bishop
g5 so i i wanted to leave that to her
so
after castle she went knight f5
95 this makes sense right that knight
wants to jump to c4 or
you know limit some of my mobility in
the queen side center
cuts my queen from getting that side so
why to move
should we take that knight or
is it a rook we care about that rook
let's not lose it
any
rebuttals from
for the argument we gotta take tonight
it is really
this is too bright
i'm not complaining i just can't really
see any faces behind it so
a lot of people in the chat are just
like yeah we gotta take it but the
problem is your pieces are not ready i i
don't disagree yeah your pieces are not
ready but this right now i said
now or never type of thing because if it
gets to see well good luck taking that
so you have to take it
if i guess this if this was a light
square bishop and it was on d3 i would
have probably argued against taking
but right now you got to take it and now
that the thing is
um
this is a very very interesting diagonal
it's very defenseless it has a lot of
fun little
ideas so you gotta go bishop a3 but i
did
and
um it's funny i was i always talk about
how to well i call it lazy chest but i
feel like that's a weird term i don't
want to count i don't want to sit there
and spend 30 minutes calculating a line
that i feel like my opponent is also
calculating
so it just feels weird to me because
then we get into who can calculate
deeper and keep their train of thoughts
better type of battle and i want to
avoid those because
chess is not the main thing i do these
days and i'm not as sharp as a lot of
the other opponents i play they are
doing tactics every day i'm not i'm
teaching every day i have exams every
day or i'm planning my next move in you
know school or whatever so it's not the
right move for me to get into a
calculation battle with somebody
so for example this move for me it i was
i didn't start thinking i didn't start
calculating it okay i take it then i'm
gonna get my bishop there there i didn't
go move by move i went for what i
thought the position needed and i tried
to compare if i take it and give up the
exchange with if i don't take it and
that that knight gets to c4 which one is
more comfortable for me which one is
more comfortable for opponent so the way
i play chess is more comparing my
positions more kind of like blocking
whatever the opponent wants it's a
little bit different style than
calculate calculate calculate
so i don't know if that's the right move
for you when i was younger i loved
calculating i would sit here for an hour
and i'll just calculate as long as i
could
so
my point being
if you're trying to calculate rook a5
and you actually try to calculate find
the weird checkmate somewhere i don't
think that'll work
um but it's not about tactics it's about
you have to it's like understanding of
the position some positions do require
depot calculations and you there is no
other options you have to sit there you
have to calculate you have to find the
best move or you will lose or you will
lose your advantage either way so
as long as it's not one of those
situations and you can just calculate by
comparing positions by trying to come up
with
does this actually benefit my positions
or
instead of trying to come up with
checkmates if it exists i feel like
that's that's kind of something that you
have to decide for your own but for me
this this is the way i play chess
most days
so
if you're playing together i hope we
never have to get into calculation
battle
wait
i think the game we had um we didn't get
into a calculation battle i tried to
make it a calculator
oh
nice
for me
um but now i am remembering some of the
games that i've had in that symbol and i
was trying to avoid
super deep calculations and
well for a few of them i kind of had to
but
all right anyways i call it lazy chest
but i don't think that's the right term
i think we should come come up with like
maybe mature chests
i don't know
anyways um
i thought that my bishop
in this diagonal and my knight trying to
get here is worth way more than that
rook would be i didn't have i didn't
really have like an estimate oh this is
gonna be plus 2.5 or whoa this is gonna
be actually why is it plus five oh the
knight went the wrong direction well
good for me
uh but it's like i didn't have an exact
estimate of what it should be but i kind
of knew what i wanted to do for example
here playing knight d3 is
great it still holds a lot of advantage
and i probably would have played this if
i didn't see c4 for me c4 was clear
opponent is not going to take that if
they do
there's a whole bunch of checks that she
would have to deal with so she's not
gonna take it
and wait she did never mind
sorry i really thought she didn't
but again this is this is like plus five
and a half but again my whole point was
i didn't sit here and calculate if she
takes it i'm gonna go this then then
that then that i just knew if she takes
then i have that diagonal i have that
file i'm good to go
anyways
um
yep so whoa it's been a little while
since i've seen
this
game so i mean i remember how it ends
but sometimes i forget how
beautiful this knight d3 was
anyways i feel like i'm just sitting
here giving myself compliments at this
point
so 93 it's really great because if they
take it kaboom checkmate coming up
93 very clear idea i want to jump up i
want to jump up here give you a little
bit of checkmate
so she tried to stop it i still went
knight c5
now i didn't even have i got the the
sacrificed peace exchanged back as well
and now i have to figure out how to get
the queen involved this is a clear
target if i eat it is pretty checkmate
right so i went for it she tried to stop
me
i tried to go for different type of
checkmate again it's all very practical
i'm also thinking rk1 is good but see if
i play rk1 then i give you a little bit
of a new idea and i'm sure somebody
could argue that this is also
advantageous and they would find a cool
way of continuing this but for me if i
do something and then you do something
and then you're happy i'm not playing
that line so rk1 didn't sit well with me
because it would give my opponents
happiness
oh i feel like this is the the anti that
um utilitarian philosophy
idea
whatever you do that gives people the
most happiness i think this is the the
anti that
oh i don't think my my health heretics
minor would be happy
but
anywho um
whatever you do the move that you do you
should not bring your opponent happiness
so
nice queen b2 made the most sense to me
i'm going to check my that should make
you happy she stopped it then i'm poking
a bit the rook again you move it great
if you don't move it i'll take it she
moved it and now my idea was well i mean
i could try to continue activating queen
but
i mean i mean i'm also assuming maybe
queen b8 is looking a little nice going
somewhere here
yeah this is also advantageous of plus
six what else what do i need in the game
i went for d5 and my idea is well
everything else is great so so i don't
want to move them
but i mean queen bee it's still super
winning so i went here
she took i pushed
she can't really take because she could
but checkmate so
i believe she just attacked this a
little bit and again i could take this
but i really wanted to just make it as
simple for me as possible
um my queen and rook are attacking here
so i'm going to continue attacking there
so i just wanted queen b8 and i think
she i
she resigned or she ran a time but this
is like the checkmate's upcoming so she
can't prevent it my whole point being i
gave you this game not just because of
not just to show off okay maybe a little
uh but the main idea was to kind of talk
to you about how to calculate and
this was the opening that i wasn't super
clear with queen d7 didn't make too much
sense to me and i think that was kind of
the whole point of why she played it
because
queen d7 kind of goes against a lot of
the ideas that i have she never played
c5 and
c5 is a huge
part of this opening yeah so you know
for me that was wait i'm gonna i'm not
gonna say never because well
the c pawn moved anyways but the whole
point of this um
for me the a huge point of french as
black is to do this c5 at some point all
right i'm gonna run through another game
really quickly before we close
i left the best for the last
now
because we're gonna be talking about
knight f6 ideas from next week i think
this is a great
transition
we are going to be talking mainly about
e5s but i am also a huge fan of bishop
g5
and um
i thought bishop g5 in this game would
be also appropriate yeah this was indeed
this was the last round of the same
years championship 2020
and it was kind of fun because my
opponent you remember i showed you a
game i had with abrahamian a little bit
earlier and i said she always plays
vinegar right well in this game she
didn't and
it was kind of uh you know it was very
clear that she didn't have as much
experience as she did in vinover because
i'll show you why
um for me i
this is this pawn structure is not that
common so it doesn't happen as much for
me this like d4 versus e6 with the
double pawns so i just know general
ideas of what i was doing
and i also knew that you know this is
the last round if she wins she's getting
a few thousand extra dollars so i knew
she did this she really wanted to win
and i assumed she had something prepared
and i didn't want to walk into her
preparations so what i went for is i
know the main lines are something with
like knight here or queen here or spawn
or
something that
she would know better so i went for what
i usually play in my sicilians a lot of
the time in sicilian every anytime i
want to confuse the opponent i just
throw in a queen d3 there and somehow it
always sticks
so i went for that
my thought process was like you know
what i'm gonna long castle soon so i'm
just gonna go queen d3 we'll see what
she does
i was assuming she's gonna try and pile
up and play c5 at some point maybe go
like f5 and you know try to get c5 she
did go for f5 indeed i gotta move the
knights i went knight c3 i wanted to
still maintain some control over center
she went c6 which is logical um c5 also
i'm suing considering but
because of my knight on c3 that makes it
a lot more harder for her
so she just wants c6 logical
my castle
now i'm not so sure about 97 i know for
i know for sure no i can't say for a
fact because she might have had this
prepared but uh during the game she was
taking more time and i could also see
her face on the camera so i knew that
she was not comfortable
in this position this wasn't something
that happens to her a lot and um
i'm assuming b5 would be in a nice
second best move idea she went knight of
knights d7 then to go f6
and here i was like okay
well i could just go knight f3 i could
just try to get the bishop out but i
want to do something that will make her
uncomfortable at least she'll spend a
few minutes on the clock
so i went to f4
and she went knight f6 which is logical
for her right
again there's some maybe queen c7 better
maybe b5 better but knight f6 does make
sense controlling some of these squares
i went knight f3 to me it made sense i
might want to jump knight e5 i might
want to keep it here for right now but i
don't know for sure what i want to do
with this bishop yet so i'm just going
to focus on the knight for now we can
talk about the bishop later she went b5
which
i don't know if it made sense to me
because i thought she has to do
something with the king right
short castle doesn't seem that practical
so i thought she might want to go along
castle but when she played b5 then i was
like well
i don't think that's the case either
i guess she might want to but it
definitely makes things
more
interesting for me
um so i just
i was like okay weakness let's go poke
at it
um she continued before all right i'm
gonna take a second then ask you what do
you think we should do right now do we
have is that a possibility can we take
or is that great great should we just
move this knight
your tactical decisions brought
happiness to opponent yeah that's
something that i've been it took me a
few years to get comfortable with
to not the idea of just not
don't do something
that for the soul and even if i can't
have a
like a move order for why it's bad i
would and but i know if i do it it makes
my opponent happy i don't even calculate
it that much
so
i don't know how to explain that except
lazy chess
i'm getting a few knight b1s i don't
want to go to b1
the thing is if they take it this
definitely makes things weird because
they can just
sorry
go queen b6 and both of your knights are
under attack if you take this oh boy oh
boy checkmate
so you have to take that back and they
can take this and
problems problems so yeah you can't you
you don't have the option of taking it
and as soon as you see take here give it
another thought and you see both knights
are under attack you can't defend them
both there are no real tactics here
just going to move this knight and
knight here does make sense because
you could also go to e2 but if you go to
e2 then this bishop is going to have
some serious
problems and again with knight b1 where
are you going to go after that knight a4
you might want to jump to c5 later on
worst case scenario is protecting b2 and
it's stopping this a pawn push so
in the game she went queen d5 which made
sense poking over here so i just stopped
it i also considered well this might be
useful in the future she went queen e4
now do you think we should exchange
queens or no
oh
thank you
let's do this with the almighty
lefou professor
good morning whoa where are you
any feelings thoughts
let's think about it together
if i take
um she'll take back probably the night
some might have two threads so i might
have to diffuse those she gets the night
in the outpost i could be attacking this
but i don't think it's that huge of an
attack for me the main point is this is
a weak king
without queens i'm not that comfortable
in my abilities to attack that king so i
want to be able to keep the queens on
the board so knowing that it gives me
more structures this coin is also
attacking this pawn so i should either
go here or here now the thing with queen
g3 that i didn't like was knight h5 and
it's a you know a fork so i just want
queen d2
i think a huge part of it is also the
process of elimination i don't want to
exchange coins because of weak kink i
need to protect this pawn okay i can't
go here because knight is five boom i
have to go queen d2
now after queen d2 um she went my d5 and
i remember here i actually took
sometimes calculating because to me it's
like
okay this queen is the middle of the
board
i should have some way of attacking it
because it feels so trapped but i can't
do it just yet because she's you know
attacking over here attacking over here
pinning this
attacking this so i can't just go with
like hey can i go bishop d3 and eat your
queen that's not gonna fly she'll take
this
and knight d5 now something does change
with the position one of the things that
i do tell my students
is
every time an opponent makes a move take
a second
think what is the opponent attacking
okay you figured out what is the
opponent attacking great now let's think
about what changed what did
what did change for them
now that this knight is here this queen
is no longer defending the pawn for
example
now this does give me more opportunities
to want to take now
there are also other ideas to consider
because
um
for some reason engine is saying g4 i
didn't really play g4 because
i mean i assume you take
bishop g2 you take this there is no
follow-up but the idea is if you do take
bishop d3 and boom the queen is trapped
now
again
opponent is not obligated to take it she
could simply take on f4 and that's kind
of what doesn't sit well with me so the
idea of g3 is more comfortable but for
me i do remember i thought about this g3
and i did see if take bishop d3a trapped
the queen but the problem is what if
queen e3 what if she just wants to
exchange queens i'm not comfortable with
that i would much rather not to exchange
those queens
so
for me i i realize that if i take
and if she takes
for some reason i was more comfortable
with this
i thought even if i do take it
and i can still activate this knight i
can do g3 bishop g2 i thought this would
be a fine choice
um
but i thought my c6 gives her the most
um mistaking options because if i play
g3 queen e3 is very forced if you don't
play queen of three your queen is kind
of trapped so you have to go there
so after knight d5 i took and she
she didn't find the best move she went
for bishop d6
after bishop d6 what do you think is a
good idea for white
you've already eaten a pond so that
might be giving you a bit of a
i guess edge
so what do we think
g3 yeah beautiful they adapt g3 as well
they want to eat this let's protect it
and you have to calculate take and i
think her mistake was she did not
calculate
my bishop b5 first she might have
considered bishop d3 and you know her
queen of three runs away right so i
think she might have forgotten about she
might have mistakenly forgot about this
i remember also i was trying to figure
out when to play knight e5 because 95
also stops queen f3 right but to me
bishop b5 was more natural clear you
move the queen now i have 95 check now i
can trap your queen
now with the queen trap i think here she
realized she was kind of toast but she
still wanted to push for it which is
very logical and i think she was hoping
i would take and you know she would take
and
maybe she would still have some counter
play and i really didn't want to deal
with that oh i do remember here i was
also low on clock and my cat kept
jumping around and blocking the camera
and i have to keep picking him up
putting him away
beautiful clips out there the arbiters
are still remember those
so um
i didn't want to risk it so when she
played knight city i was like okay i'm
not ready to take let's go bishop c6 i'm
attacking more the queen is still toast
so i'm still fine i'm going to keep
pushing
and so she took i took now this feels
better because you know i'm attacking
you rook so you have to move it i
already know your next move now i can
exchange these knights i'm going to win
a pawn great
now if i move my bishop get the knight
here i'm great but still not winning i
mean it's still i don't say not winning
it is winning but you have to be careful
because there's still a lot of potential
for mistakes for example here she played
f6
the best note that engine is suggesting
is i guess moving the queen oh no
actually maybe i don't know i don't know
i don't think there's a huge of a
difference to me knight c for logical i
want to exchange stuff off she went
bishop before boom i'm moving the queen
i might want to do d5 next i did d5 next
i'm gonna exchange off i'm gonna eat a
little bit i'm i'm gonna start
threatening checkmates
she took i took
she tried to
pin it a little
a few checks here and there a few checks
here and there
i didn't i wasn't here like
i wasn't trying to find checkmate i was
just trying to get out of the trouble
first so make sure i'm not dropping
pieces
then i can try to find checkmate i was i
mean i was sure there is advantage here
but i wasn't sure if i actually have
enough to make the checkmate and i don't
see engines showing me oh here's a
mating two that you missed but the point
being that not everything is about
checkmate yeah if you see it do it
but it's really important to kind of
just
about do what the position needs don't
just do what you want so this position
right now
the position needed me to save the
knights that's a weird thing to say
let's just let's just go with it though
i if i lose the knights two rooks versus
the queen and a bunch of pawns it's
gonna be so much harder than
if i kept the night so i don't care how
much i need to give you checks i want to
save that night so i did and i think
here she actually resigned
but yeah all right um
i just kind of wanted to take today and
do that smooth transition and show you
some weird slash cool ideas hopefully
that made sense we are going to be doing
switch to twitch and uh showing you
doing your game analysis so make sure to
show up on twitch in the next five
minutes or so with your games on a
leeches link format
and
yeah see you next week and we're going
to be talking a lot about
staynets
bye
[Music]
you